citizens of the reject Nation we have
only three episodes left of Brooklyn
nine nine
what episode is it John season three
episode 21 it's called maximum security
that's what I like to hear all we
actually leave a like today that you
also know that prepper headed his whole
thing we didn't review the edit once
we don't review these in their hands on
their hands so prepper I hope you did a
good job today yeah because if not if
this reaction sucks it has nothing to do
with the way we reacted people love this
Arc don't screw it up it's all about how
you edited it
don't mess it up
don't mess it up prepper
except not you know
because we're not I was waiting my final
punchline
which was I don't have a punchline
hey you'll be on SNL in no time
[Music]
blamo scrubs kablamo Captain Holt's
brain teaser and found the location of
our secret meeting the answer the broom
closet in your face in who's face now
yours no my presence is not puzzle
related I just followed Terry into a
dark closet
hey you saw the puzzle before me
nerds I'm thinking we must be in the
wrong place no trust me we're definitely
in the right place I'm 100 sure about
this oh I'm gonna solve the puzzle we
did oh we did yeah we're in the wrong
place
remember the only people we can trust
with this information are in this room
and Genevieve we share life I tell her
everything fine the people in this room
and Genevieve Genevieve's mom also knows
but she's in a coma dead any second oh
my God a white woman in prison in Texas
she murdered three people so we're
sending a detective in undercover as an
inmate to get close to her you know if
the ladies touching each other's bits
and there's kind of some lame Jazz
playing
Perot is gross but correct this facility
is a violent place filled with hardened
criminals we need to send someone who
can blend in sir
be honor to take on this challenging
assignment
I can be a badass you're raising your
hand right now we're in a meeting I just
assumed Diaz would be the prisoner
nothing personal is just you know she's
terrifying thank you sir
dismissed is that December sick maybe a
little bit in his voice you're not going
to try to convince us Mahler was the
original punk rocker again are you no
the music is a classic counter Espionage
maneuver I don't want to be overheard
since you mentioned it Mahler was one in
your face bad boy right
he was now before we quote unquote Barry
pimento we need to quote-unquote open an
investigation find a quote unquote
corpse and obtain a quote unquote death
certificate kind of feel like you could
have just used air quotes I could also
wear short pants and drink from a jug
that says XXX do it yes sir but where
are we going to find a corpse we don't
need one we just need pictures for the
case File you guys get access to a
morgue imagine pimento's dirty pale body
being pulled out of a manhole after a
couple days sewer blew now squint your
eyes
hahaha
yeah since genifique started fertility
treatments it's all we talk about now
show me your waddle
[Laughter]
good work you really look like a corpse
and I'm not even wearing makeup
do you want me to break the sacred oath
I took to become a notary not a problem
because I'm a badass just like Rosa I am
going to stamp this and
violate my oath
Adrian pimento is officially deceased
all those sneaking around is
exhilarating I can feel the adrenaline
pushing through my body
coursing
Hulk out Chief don't forget you're seven
months pregnant your cervix is ripening
as we speak mentioned my cervix again
and I will rip your throat out I don't
understand you don't like it when he
talks about your cervix ripening
okay have fun they grow up so fast
you're being transferred here because
you made trouble in your last prison
stay in your lane hey you're
the rest of me three years ago in
Brooklyn Jamie Santiago uh you're going
to prison
smart another pregnant girl
she's actually pregnant too yeah that's
what I think I was thinking she's
actually pregnant right yeah
she looks pregnant
I'm in for murder because some perv on
the subway tried to touch me and I was
like did someone order a tracheotomy we
need to work on your tough talk so what
are you in for Cortez none of your damn
business I'm gonna split you like a
Sunday with Grandpa [ __ ]
it was great yeah although mean threats
generally don't involve having desserts
with your grandparents so just try again
Kim tell me what to do and I'll stab
your face off oh yeah
and spread the word that you've got to
connect on the outside that gives you
access to contraband cigarettes burner
phones pornography Amy women don't watch
they do oh yeah oh wow huh yeah
I'm sorry about pimento I mean I know
how hard it is to have a fiance
disappear because the mob and the FBI
want them dead
we're gonna throw a fake funeral to draw
out our FBI guy good plan I always
thought it would be funny to kill
somebody at a funeral
so you may not be sad but you're gonna
need to look it fine
boohoo maybe we'll get you a real thick
video or something
I say I waddle
good she's abbreviating just like we
practiced even though she hates it she's
gonna do just fine oh yeah I drilled her
for hours ew I'm sorry I just realized
what that sounded like oh that's okay
Jake I wish we'd talk like that more no
locker room Chuck where'd you get that
crap
outside so I
was yours
okay I can do that oh my gosh you're
gonna be a friend Sally from Miceli oh
no word play abort Sally I get it funny
oh it actually worked huh well people
are really starved for entertainment in
here jail as hell yeah man in the FBI is
that he's a white male of average height
and build and according to Jake he has a
scar on his hand this is a long shot but
if his name is Joe could we call him
scarja never heard that before I like it
we'll use it now funeral assignments
are you sure you want to be on the
receiving line you hate small talk now I
can turn it on when it's called four The
Bachelor is a television show Andre
agassi's at it again I too avoid gluten
I want the rest of you checking out the
crowd for anyone suspicious oh I'm sorry
I'm interrupted no we just all came in
separately and then started chatting you
know Breezy stuff The Bachelors of
television show Andre agassi's at it
again
this is her first time eating in the
dining hall where she chooses to sit is
very important feel good she's headed
towards that table of hot blonde girls
wait a minute no they're Nazis the
hotties are Nazis they're hot Seasons oh
no what I want I'm The Only store in
this prison I didn't see your name on
the outside of the prison unless your
name is Texas State Penitentiary comma
Spring Valley unit ah this is bad
people think I'm gonna say this but she
should have said with the hot seat ah go
Amy go go Amy always sit with the hot
seat we called you in because your first
contact with figgis was a disaster why
because our smuggling plan backfired and
she threatened to kill me yes we need a
new plan and I've got one I need to step
to her yeah Amy this isn't High School
Musical too yeah and it is an High
School Musical three senior year all
right maybe we need a signal in case
things go south oh I know scratch your
butt no that's no good whatever but it's
just for real I think I can handle it
I've made it through 20 years of
adulthood without scratching my butt in
public
Amy Amy come here come on
come on come on
[Music]
Hello thank you so much for coming high
five
detective pimento didn't want his
funeral to feel stuffy condolences my
man
[Laughter]
handshakes weren't working you couldn't
see the inside of the thumb webbing Gina
came up with an Artful solution I'm very
sorry for your loss
get some
what about the other hand
any sign of Scar Joe not yet what does
Scarlett Johansen actually shows up I
know Cameo MCU Beyonce you did really
leave just act sad about it I'll pretend
to be sad I'll make myself cry watch
that's not how this works
or is it
no don't confront her when she's armed
fine
seriously she was at lunch she didn't
have a weapon she had a fork that's like
four tiny shifts on a stick
foreign
what the hell socks are just a noose
waiting to be braided
you don't think I'm tough enough to do
this
okay you know what fine you're right I
don't but it's only because Maura is so
much more terrifying than we anticipated
but she has a full back tattoo of
herself stabbing a guy
I want to see it
[Music]
oh my God they actually look
intimidating for first time
[Music]
he's just a glove-wearing freak with
beautiful hands why did he run then he's
a big pocket I guess the bereft are easy
targets also Scully here's your wallet
back
keeping a low profile just like we
discussed I'm really impressed with you
too you disagreed with the best strategy
but talked it through like adults well
the key is trust I trust her to stay out
of danger and she trusts me oh [ __ ] I
did because that order was crap I did
the right thing and it's insulting that
you don't see that hey hey the baby
could hear you yelling and It's
upsetting him it's a fake baby Charles I
mean the baby's a cover
truth is I'm the one that's not tough
enough to be in here the woman I love
unarmed locked up with all these
murderers it's just too much for me
oh my God Amy go to him
hey Cortez you're late for your
appointment quit touching me oh I don't
need checkups every two seconds
wow you're so tough and I'm just a
beautiful intellectual
I love beating up doctors can I get in
here no she's mine back off I'm kicking
for two
thought it was a skyjo
I don't want to talk about it talking
about your feelings it's for losers I
guess Adele's a loser in your world
this is it I'm leaving you're in charge
I'll take extra good care of her Jake
just let her do her thing but this is
Texas so also make sure she doesn't
somehow get the death penalty
stay tough Cortez
you're touching her boobs should I turn
away or I'm not touching her boobs she's
tiny on the screen I'm just saying
goodbye man I'm trying to give you
privacy no don't turn that's what makes
it weird
I don't know your process am I hitting
on anything here the roof thing sounds
pretty good very well let's throw
something off the roof and then we'll
get back to work
high five
I quite like them now
yeah
it's a nice force on that holy Killa
good job I'm beating the crap out of
that doctor you got balls I'm not a
Bruiser I'm a psycho even better nice
job Cortes
oh I touch your boob I can't tell Jake
[Laughter]
hard of gold on that Charles Boyle
you could survive prison sure could
definitely a hundred percent no doubts
here in my mind geez send me right now
let's do a crime and get me caught the
whole time I was watching I was like you
know out of anyone I know if you jump
yep yep yep John could fit right in walk
in find the biggest baddest mofo and
knock them out
and then every other phone we're talking
about women's prison right every woman I
find just knock them out knock them out
a minority in this women's prison I
could do whatever I I need to to survive
I'm clocking chins brah come see stars
with me if you identify as a woman sure
can you go to a woman's prison that is a
great question I'm sure many of debate
is being argued over that
like just across the swath of time we
live in right now oh that'd be
fascinating because that's that's a
great question
it's an excellent question I don't know
I feel like it's it's it's more likely
for a trans man to go to a Men's prison
than it would be for a trans woman to go
to a woman's prison because I feel like
that's the kind of spite we like in our
society where we're like nah nah you're
just a dude trying to get in the women's
locker room
you're just an opportunist with this
lifestyle of yours so we're gonna make a
big show out of putting you in the Men's
prison but wow I don't know that that's
just my cynical guesstimate everyone's
favorite word you make things it's too
political John that's right man it's all
I care about always just reading the
politics I love politics dude Stephanie
Beatrice been showing emotion lately
oats you've been acting she's been
showing that she's more than just dry
humor yeah she's she's the real deal
trying to get movie roles now yeah so it
starts man yeah you distinguish yourself
on a comedy comedy show with some
teardrops
and uh I like the I did like the prison
storyline a lot quite I am quite worried
for Amy but then it's nice to see her do
something really different that doesn't
rely on her being very particular in a
neat freaking anal nerd yeah but like
get to show a really different side of
her stuff I really like it a lot quite
competent she's clearly learned things
from Rosa let's look up and make sure
she's actually pregnant
I think somebody commented because I
I've been watching this season being
like I feel like she's pregnant and but
I don't want to say something in case
I'm like oh that's a because you know
you could easily if you're wrong about
that that it's defensive then you're
calling somebody fat yeah pregnant
Brooklyn nine nine see because because
yeah the way they frame her you I watch
enough TV now to know I just don't like
the way they framed this woman looks
like she's pregnant yeah yeah
behind something
you know the long the big clothes the
bag your clothes and then this episode
like they brought out that that
pregnancy bump for for Rosa and I was
like wait a minute okay yeah I see what
you're doing here clever yeah there's
plenty there's plenty of shot the way
she's framed a lot of the season I was
like she looks pregnant but definitely
I'm wrong I'm just calling her fatty fat
fat [ __ ] yeah
but hey you dodged that bullet I did
that kid exists now I didn't Melissa
McCarthy pregnant for years
that's just gonna be an extra
concentrated baby it's gonna be such a
gray baby Rebel Wilson recently lost
recently he stopped to get pregnant yep
uh-huh okay uh who who we got who we got
Gabourey Sidibe is pregnant yeah this is
gonna go if we keep it for a very long
time yeah Jonah Hill was pregnant for a
long time yeah there's been a lot of
pregnant people out there
people love when you talk about their
bodies that's one thing I've learned
especially when they're pregnant or when
they could be pregnant yeah people love
to be mistakenly pregnant oh my God
that's the best you should be flattered
to be mistaken for pregnancy I thought
you were pregnant because you were glow
yes yes the radiance not your not your
baby bump yeah yeah but uh
no that was cool and that is Tony
Soprano's sister I believe
yeah you would know you don't I don't
because you haven't taken the time to
watch The Wire I should watch the wires
six feet under there's a certain period
of like before the great glut of TV that
I'm still kind of holding out for like
okay I'll watch yeah the wire Sopranos
six feet under probably Dexter that's
still like kind of in the before times
where you had like a couple main
purveyors of event TV instead of now
where everybody's got TV yeah everyone's
a network even people who don't make
media are now making media Walmart's
gonna have their own streaming service
apparently uh I like the way this was
written though with Jake uh being overly
protective and have it what they did
with both story lines is
they both had a kept up appearances and
then it was about getting to the main
characters of each storyline Stephanie
Beatrice and Andy Samberg but the main
characters but wanna uh and showing that
there's actually something underneath
this Veil yeah yeah absolutely and that
there's a lot of
main worry between the two of them
that's like the connecting emotional
thread there yeah but with the guy with
the scarred hand show up to the wedding
um
yeah it's a great question I guess I
don't know to make sure to verify to
check up on the situation to see if
everything is an FBI legit yeah true but
I don't know maybe it's maybe they
figure like well this will be a way for
him to you know like really lay the case
to rest you know we made all this
evidence maybe it'll come out just to
just to make sure he'd finish the job or
something
but he didn't show up clearly he was
smarter than that maybe
fake my own death oh yeah
can you imagine reviews My comeback
video again
yeah that would be a great marketing
strategy one year off the grid dead
everyone just assumes yeah we found we
found his teeth and then I could start
doing other videos or work with other
YouTubers where it's like I think Greg
Alba was spotted in public was this
filmed before the death or or or or or
or is he not actually dead is he like
Tupac in us right I swear I saw Greg
to do is come to my home and they would
have seen I've been here the whole time
yes nobody investigated your death
you just took your word for it it took
whoever announced it
you make your own I'm dead video that'd
be crazy it'd be such a massive video
hey citizens the reject Nation if you're
seeing this I'm dead I mean you'd be mad
at me for faking my own death and
preying on your emotions like that uh
but you'd also be conflicted because
you'd be a little relieved I'm still
alive yeah it's not as bad as as faking
somebody else's death because it's just
your own death yeah be a fascinating
experiment sure we should try it I hope
I say this often enough in videos that
way when I do actually die I become a
myth yes people think when you die
eventually during a reaction people will
think oh great this is just great part
of his own death yeah and then you'll
have people waiting for decades just
like nah every year that passes the joke
gets funnier
he's just waiting until it's as funny as
it could possibly be
I would just come back in a way of like
what's up guys Greg here all right we're
gonna watch tonight
gotta leave the Mystique that's what
will keep people around you gotta either
acknowledge it or you have to
acknowledge it in a way that makes it
more confusing
I would oh my God that would be so fun
yeah just a year
they're so messed up go travel the world
oh we gotta be funny though and then
come back and show people how much
living you've done in the year they
thought you were dead
travel the world yeah I'd have to go off
the grid though that'd be really hard
build houses in Africa and I traveled to
oh my God
what are you talking about I went to
South America and you know helped you
know what are you talking about
irrigated before in the next year
editing the Breaking Bad universe and
timeliner
With Better Call Saul and El Camino
Incorporated exactly yeah each one of
those has flashbacks and jumping around
time and I would pinpoint it's exactly
when it goes out like okay this better
this Breaking Bad in episode four of
season three that flashback has to be
the first thing we see so then it
wouldn't even make sense when you stack
them together because there's no real
flow
but it'll still be out of place
flashbacks just all stacked together I
don't know but it's perfect because then
you can just tell people that they're
not sophisticated enough to understand
that they're not true fans to appreciate
what you've done and also you know like
when El Camino came out and then when
characters returned and Better Call Saul
they didn't they don't de-age them so
it's like especially jarring oh really
they're just like ah you'll suspend
disbelief it's fine yeah
that's what I would do for my year so
then you really can't be mad at me
because they'll be like at least he
brought us
[Music]
the freaking bad Universe now yeah every
time you fake your death you should go
away and then you should re-cut some
either much beloved or much maligned
pieces like do a toe for Grace cut of
something that people like you know wish
was better and just come back with like
all three movies of something cut into
one perfect cut well what it would be is
mainly better to call Saul in the
beginning obviously of course
interspliced with flashbacks of Walter
White
that way
it's kind of like the show mind Hunter
whenever they were teasing the BTK
killer okay like okay I guess we're
building to this guy he's out there he's
teaching chemistry now but he won't be
soon yeah that's what we're doing and
you go full oh my God it'd be kind of
cool actually wouldn't it though
honestly that could be like a black show
flashback Fade to Black again continue
the show dude that could be like a
decade-long project that turns into some
kind of beautiful white whale of you
know oh yeah and I want to cut it up in
episodes it would be
our export
you have so many computers and so many
props you just have a a like a warehouse
it's like the [ __ ] they used to mine
cryptocurrency is what you will be
rendering of this video on it won't be
I'm like it keeps getting blocked
maybe I'll export it one quality in
Thailand order YouTube stop blocking it
I'm trying to get the public to watch
this
500 terabytes of this yeah
we'd like uh say six seasons A Better
Call Saul roughly 10 episodes yeah we're
looking at about like 120 hours of
television problems good
good and then uh
how many days is that
It's gotta be yeah
I believe it is one long uncut yup I
like it you know if you're a real fan
you'll watch it yeah totally 100 you
won't pause it
no but then the problem is you'll get
people doing that you'll get people
trying to Guinness World Records you'll
get people with their own toilet chair
with like a live streaming camera just
to prove it and they'll have like you
know [ __ ] constantly being delivered to
them they'll get bed sores watching it
there's actually a cool version of this
to be made there is a a good idea in
here
yeah you just keep teasing well oh
that'd be cool yeah
and then after a while it'll be like we
really forgot about that small guy oh he
shows up once in a while
yeah
wow this really changed directions and
protagonist it's like a whole other kind
of Showdown this is like way more
fast-paced all of a sudden
I mean don't get me wrong character
shit's just as great as it's ever been
but
yeah but then the the but then you know
Better Call Saul also goes to the after
breaking bad and then it would be
bookended yeah
no every every angle you could poke
jokingly at this there's also an answer
as to how this would work and be kind of
cool I think and then it would also
undercut the flashback usage because the
flashbacks are so specific towards each
episode to complement the story they're
telling them so that it would just feel
like I don't get the point of that
flashback
okay Walt is doing his thing
yeah these guys could pass gonna ever
cross
to the first time viewer
oh imagine if that's the way you're one
of those people who like only sees the
ultimate cut of Kill Bill for the first
time or you always see this cut of all
of Breaking Bad for your first
experience Brooklyn 99 gave me an idea
guys dude it's idea day it's an
inspirational show it is an
inspirational show what's a good Arc
will do thanks for being here and we'll
talk to you guys soon peace
[Music]